hey guys tim ferriss here all through
the for our body for out the stand the
other thing and i wanted to tell you
about some physical learnings that i've
had recently I've had chronic elbow
tendonitis so medial epicondylitis is
this golfer's elbow right here tennis
elbow right here
that's surgery on this L surgery on the
shoulder lots of issues but the elbows
have been really debilitating every six
months or so if I'm doing hard training
I have to take a very long break and
stop everything effectively it becomes
so painful that I can't brush my teeth
without shooting pain right here
I've largely addressed it in part thanks
to you guys and a bunch of tips that I
got so I want to show a few things that
have worked for me and the first is
going to be this right here this is the
arm aid and it straps to your leg like
so and I'll show you how this works once
I get it put on Molly
my pump right there doesn't chew on it
you have your yack bun enjoy your yack
bow so doing manual therapy on your arms
is very difficult this allows you to use
a lever like so and you can change the
physics and so on sizing by this slider
here and then you can do different types
of extension flexion and move your arm
through this entire range of motion it
is really spectacular piece of equipment
that was referred to me by people who
are very serious rock climbers okay so
this is this is number one this is the
are made
weird-looking device but very very
useful and you can also rotate it very
easily and honestly go to the armaid
website just to see the product video
because it's amazing it's hilarious and
really really well done by this guy I
think you should go to state fairs he
would sell a million of them alright the
next and I'll take this thing off my leg
is a little unexpected multi-purpose
also and that is the Hitachi Magic Wand
ladies okay so this is not well it could
be used for clitoris but not in this
case this is a purchase to add good
vibrations here in San Francisco it is
well known as a female pleasuring device
but in this case the
original this is not the newer version
the original set on high apparently has
the proper frequency Hertz for relaxing
hypertonic muscles meaning if my
forearms are effectively spasmed and
really really tight and this was
referred to me by a Russian medical
massage expert who actually flew in to
work on my arms and you would place it
on the muscle belly or at the end or the
insertion points for say 20 to 30
seconds to get the muscles to relax and
if I get the muscles to relax they're
not pulling right since it is a tendon
they're not pulling on this medial
epicondyle right here so touching
magic wand there you have it and of
course there are many different things
you can do with this that is for a
different programming this is for the
family folks we're not going to cover
that right now all right next we have
this device and in terms of how much I
would use all these the armaid i would
use on a daily basis once or twice just
for a few minutes each arm the touching
magic wand just takes 20-30 seconds so I
would do that again once or twice a day
perhaps when I wake up and then before
bed and this right here this is a
metolius grip saver plus and there are
different versions there's also the
handmaster plus which might have been
first hello Molly and the way this works
is very simple you put your fingers into
these loops and you squeeze the ball and
then you extend with your hands so one
of the theories and it may not be a
theory may be fact related to the causes
of flexor tendinitis is that you have
weak extensors and I use a big bucket of
rice for this as well where I'll stick
my hand in and then expand my fingers
but this is a great device that you can
travel with very easily you could
potentially get rubber bands which some
people do well right but this guy works
really well all right next up and this
seems overwhelming but it doesn't have
to be some of these are weird these are
the rubber bands all this is Bach on
Amazon so these are fing finger bands by
I leo a yl
oh my okay enjoy your bed these these
things all right these are cups and
traditionally in Chinese medicine you
might use moxibustion which is mugwort
and you would have a glass bowl that I
would have something lit underneath it
and then that would create pressure when
it's put on or create a difference in
pressure lines put on the skin cap it
sucks up the skin so that is Chinese
cupping these are very useful because
you don't have to go through all that
you just apply pressure you push down
and then think you have this type of
suction I first ran into these when I
was doing the Tim Ferriss experiment TV
show and the drumming episode where I
had to train and drumming for a few days
and then go on stage to a sold-out
audience with foreigner and drum my
forearms were killing me
they just weren't used to the stresses
and a massage therapist was working on
different band members for different
bands it was the warm-up back during
that and she used one of these and took
the pain away like that
so cupping is the next one and these are
very cheap like 20 bucks 30 bucks and
they will leave a huge hickey if you
leave them on for a few minutes put one
of these right in between my French
shoulders when he was working on his
laptop once gigantic purple well like
this hickey that will last a week or so
so be forewarned all right so we have
those all these things aside for maybe
the are made very easy to travel it of
course if you have checked luggage you
could take this thing might have to
explain to the TSA what this is all
about all right now I am saving perhaps
the best for last
these are very very good the first one
is the thera-band
and this can be used for tennis elbow or
can be used for golfer's elbow and the
operative principle with this and the
next thing that I'm going to show you is
eccentric movement so for addressing
tendinopathy Achilles tendinitis
tendinosis eccentric exercise has been
shown to produce some really dramatic
improvements sometimes as much as like
an 80% decrease in severity of symptoms
in a week or so and the way you would
you would use this there are different
videos online you can find but to do the
negative so the flexors do this in
effect so I the negative movement would
be that how do we mimic this well get
the arm like this get into full flexion
and then grab this like soups that's the
wrong way grab this it's a little
confusing to do like that straight my
arms and then that's the negative right
so it's just this movement here and you
do that say 15 repetitions one to three
sets to three times a day
I'm not that ambitious I would do it
once or twice a day I can see a very
significant decrease in symptoms this
can also be used for golfer's elbow
there are lots of different exercises
you can find online but for this little
bad boy right here specifically the way
that I find it easiest is of curling it
in like this coming around well and then
extending and there you have the
negative all right
that's number one the next eccentric
exercise is using this right here this
was also indicated by a very high level
rock climber so you can see I have
fractional Olympic plates this adds up
to I think about 3 pounds and you have 1
pound 1 pound 1/2 pound all right so
these are fractional Olympic plates that
you can put on a barbell actually here
we just have construction clamps
basically you can get at any hardware
store for probably 2 X 3 bucks and what
I'm going to do with this also for the
golf was golfers in golf owes Alva golf
okay whoa issue is the following so we
start here and further away you get of
course the heart of the physics are and
I'm using this this particular pole that
has notches so I can remember how far
I am you could just use a marker you can
use a dowel broom handle whatever it
might be and coming here and then we're
just doing negatives okay slow negative
down to the floor then up I'm not
bringing it back up myself that's the
concentric the positive it I want to do
that and then we would just do this
again 10 to 15 repetitions one to three
sets a day and that's it and a lot of
folks including myself have seen the
symptoms of pain sensitivity and so on
literally decreased by 50 plus percent
in one to two weeks in my case it took
about a week so very very cool piece of
equipment that is very very easy to put
together and those are the primary tools
there are all sorts of little goodies
that I could use lacrosse balls for
rolling things out
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah but the 80/20
you know the 20% of all the tools that I
tried that have given me the most
benefit are those I've shown you and
then these here these are compression
armbands these are these specifically
are from 2xu now there are also some
some other good versions from slingshot
makes makes another one that works very
well a lot of world-class power lifters
use this mighty bark mark bells involved
with this this is 2x you and how aware
these during workouts for compression
just to decrease inflammation and add
some support since I have been here here
and here
elbows are all jacked up from gymnastics
training at 38 but there you have it
guys
hope you find it useful thanks for
watching everybody I would love to share
more videos with you if you would like
to see them please subscribe right here
and I will get to making more for you